owen wilson
wilson people do impressions of i'm told
you do uh
you do a pretty me now in wilson
i do yeah
i learned that when probably over 10
years ago i remember trying it out at
the haha cafe open mic when i was 17. no
one knew who he was in the crowd they
were like who's owen and i was ahead of
the time
owen wilson knows that you do an
impression of him right yeah three years
ago my dad
met him at a a job site my dad's a fence
contractor if you need if you need a
gate conan you let me know and i'll let
my dad know sure i would i would be
honored to have your dad build me a gate
just picturing my gate around you yeah i
want a gate surrounding i want a gate
that separates myself from my son
from my 14 year old son yeah my my dad
was working at a house in malibu okay
putting up a gate and he sees owen walk
by and he goes hey owen i'm melissa
viesner's dad she does an impression of
you and then owen goes oh yeah i've seen
you it's pretty good yeah wow it's very
good and then they were chatting for a
while
and then at the end of the conversation
my dad goes hey owen be careful over
there okay because there's a beehive
just watch out and owen goes okay thanks
yeah
and then
uh three years later i meet owen and i
go oh and i love you so much oh man nice
to meet you and then the first thing he
says is
i met your dad
he helped me out with some bees
he helped me out with some bees yes yes
i love that if you hadn't known what he
was talking about that would have been
so funny yeah god hadn't told you and
you met owen if i met owen wilson and he
just said yeah i met your dad he helped
me out with some bees i'd be
i would love it i would love not knowing
the context
a lot of joy
you you talk about your doubt are your
parents funny did you get your sense of
humor from your parents yeah i did um
my dad is the goofy one the people
pleaser he's sensitive he loves musicals
my mom is like the honest
uh
just you know sometimes she's just
brutally honest you know sometimes
she'll look at me and she'll go like
your mustache is coming in take care of
that you're on a show now
so there's you know but they're so
different they're kind of like um
i share this on stage they're they're
like you know planes trains and animal
bills yeah i see i know i watch all the
classics okay good for me good for you i
was you got to give me a chance to say
good for you
good for me
you got to give someone a chance all
right all right by the way i give to
charities and that makes me a great guy
but anyway so yeah the classic steve
martin john candy
planes trains yeah so on our vhs cover
in the 90s my dad wrote his name next to
john candy's character and my mom next
to steve martin okay
and so they have arguments like in the
movie i've heard them in their room like
my mom would be like mike not everyone
needs to like you okay
people don't like me i'm okay with it
you don't see me crying my dad's like
stop it loopy okay the kids were having
a tough week i was trying to make them
laugh they don't like you mike nobody
likes you and i walk in like mom and dad
are you guys okay my mom's like i'm okay
your dad's crying nobody likes him
but he like gets upset when he when when
someone dislikes him and he wants to fix
it i identify with your dad and i don't
think i could stand i mean that's that's
rough first of all your mom doesn't
sound like she's being brutally honest
i'm sure there are people who like your
dad nobody likes you
that's not honest that's just that's
cruel
you can't say that to anybody i mean
sometimes when he's you know a little
little geeky or something my mom will be
like you know if i knew you in school
i'd beat you up
well i it sounds like a very loving
relationship it's it's very it's really
it balances out it's pretty fun it's
also you got to have parents like that
to get you into comedy that's the reason
to do it you know yeah and i think i'm
like that i think i'm silly but i could
also be pretty pissed
and and honest really
yes okay are you mad at me now
okay
i'm actually i don't want you mad at me
so i'll just you know
i'll do my best to behave